THAT THE U.S. FOUGHT INITIALLY
OVERTHROWING THE TALIBAN.
IT'S A CHAOTIC SCENE WE HAVE
SEEN JUST A SHORT TIME AGO AT
KABUL'S AIRPORT.
AFGHANS SCRAMBLING TO GET OUT,
CLINGING TO THE SIDE OF A U.S.
MILITARY PLANE AND IT TOOK ONLY
ABOUT A WEEK FOR THE TALIBAN TO
MARCH ACROSS MUCH OF AFGHANISTAN
AND TAKE KABUL.
SO, WHERE ARE WE RIGHT NOW?
AND WHAT IS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DOING AS IT EXITS
FROM THE COUNTRY?
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THIS NOW
WITH DEPUTY NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER JOHN FINER WHO IS WITH
US FROM THE NORTH LAWN OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
HE HAS LONG-TIME PUSHED FOR
ENDING AMERICA'S SO-CALLED
FOREVER WARS.
JOHN, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING WITH US.
LOOK, I KNOW THERE'S A LOT -- OF
COURSE THE BLAME GAME GOING ON
AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
LET'S JUST TALK ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
SEEING AT THIS MOMENT, DESPERATE
AFGHANS THERE AT THE AIRPORT.
WE UNDERSTAND FROM THE PENTAGON
THAT THEY'RE PLANNING TO
RELOCATE UP TO 30,000 AFGHAN
SPECIAL IMMIGRANT VISA
APPLICANTS.
CAN YOU TELL US ANYTHING MORE
ANT WHAT AMERICA IS DOING TO
HELP AFGHANS WHO PUT THEIR LIVES
IN DANGER TO HELP AMERICA?
>> THANKS, BRIANNA, FOR THAT
QUESTION.
YES, THE IMAGES THAT WE'RE
SEEING OUT OF KABUL
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT THIS
MORNING ARE VERY SERIOUS.
WE'RE GOING TO BE FOCUSSED
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF THE DAY
AND BEYOND ON ENSURING THAT THAT
AIRPORT IS SAFE AND SECURE.
YOU KNOW, THESE ARE DESPERATE
PEOPLE.
YOU USED THE WORD DESPERATE AND
I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
AND THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO QUITE
RIGHTLY ARE LOOKING FOR A WAY
OUT OR A REFUGE OR CAUGHT IN A
VERY DANGEROUS SITUATION AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHY PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS ORDERED THE EVACUATION
OF THOUSANDS OF VULNERABLE
AFGHANS BOTH PEOPLE WHO HAVE
APPLIED FOR SPECIAL IMMIGRANT
VISAS TO THE UNITED STATES AS
WELL AS OTHERS WHO ARE
VULNERABLE, ACTIVISTS, WOMEN,
JUDGES, PEOPLE WHO ARE
POTENTIALLY GOING TO BE IN THE
CROSSHAIRS GOING FORWARD THAT WE
ARE GOING TO BE FLYING OUT OF
THE COUNTRY BUT THE PREREQUISITE
OF THAT IS GETTING THIS AIRPORT
BACK SAFE AND SECURE.
THAT WILL BE THE MAIN LINE OF
EFFORT THESE FLIGHTS ALREADY
BROUGHT BY THE WAY 2,000 PEOPLE
WHO WORKED ALONGSIDE THE UNITED
STATES AND THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
TO THE UNITED STATES IN THE LAST
COUPLE WEEKS.
>> GETTING IT BACK SAFE AND
SECURE.
IS IT NOT SAFE AND SECURE RIGHT
NOW.
>> THE CONCERNS ARE THE IMAGES
THAT WE'VE ALL SEEN ON
TELEVISION AND OTHER PLACES OF
PEOPLE WALKING AROUND THE RUNWAY
AND THE TARMAC.
THE UNITED STATES HAS THE FORCES
THAT ARE NECESSARY TO BRING
STABILITY AND SECURITY TO THAT
AIRPORT.
I THINK THEY HAVE GONE A GREAT
DISTANCE TOWARDS DOING THAT
SINCE SOME OF THOSE IMAGES HAVE
AIRED.
THERE WILL BE MORE FORCES
FLOWING IN THROUGH OUT THE
COURSE OF TODAY AND TOMORROW AND
WE BELIEVE WE HAVE WHAT'S
NECESSARY TO BE ABLE TO ENABLE
THESE FLIGHTS TO CONTINUE AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE THAT IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING.
>> JOHN, WHAT ABOUT ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT AT THE
AIRPORT?
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE THEY MIGHT
BE, LOOK, FOR LACK OF A BETTER
WORD RIGHT NOW SCREWED.
WE KNOW THAT THEY ARE HOLED UP
IN THEIR HOMES IN KABUL.
WE KNOW THAT A LOT OF THEM ARE
OUT EVEN IN THE PROVINCES UNABLE
TO GET TO KABUL.
WHAT IS THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
DOING IF ANYTHING TO PROVIDE
SAFE PASSAGE FOR PEOPLE TO THE
KABUL AIRPORT SO THAT THEY
ACTUALLY CAN GET OUT IN THE
NUMBERS THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS PROMISING?
>> THE UNITED STATES HAS
COMMUNICATED TO THE TALIBAN IN
NO UNCERTAIN TERMS THEY ARE NOT
TO INTERFERE WITH THE SAFE
PASSAGE OF AFGHANS TO THE
AIRPORT WHO ARE LOOKING TO
DEPART THE COUNTRY.
AND PEOPLE WHO ARE -- WE ARE
PRIORITIZING FOR THESE FLIGHTS
THAT I'VE JUST DESCRIBED THAT
ARE GOING TO START --
>> JOHN, LET ME ASK --
>> AND JUST TO FINISH THIS,
WE'VE BEEN QUITE CLEAR TO THE
TALIBAN THAT SHOULD THEY
INTERFERE WITH THOSE EFFORTS
THEY WILL FACE SEVERE
CONSEQUENCES AND WE HAVE THE
MILITARY FORCES IN PLACE TO BE
ABLE TO EXECUTE THAT.
WE'RE NOT SEEING THEM
INTERFERING AT THIS TIME WITH
PEOPLE'S ABILITY TO GET TO THE
AIRPORT AND IT IS GOING TO BE
VERY IMPORTANT THAT THAT
CONTINUES GOING FORWARD.
NOW, BRIANNA, YOU KNOW AS WELL
AS I DO, THAT THE UNITED STATES
IS NOT IN THE POSITION NOW AND
WILL NOT BE IN A POSITION GOING
FORWARD TO PROVIDE SECURITY
THROUGHOUT THE CITY OF KABUL AND
THROUGHOUT THE NATION OF
AFGHANISTAN.
WE ARE FOCUSSED ON THE AIRPORT.
WE ARE FOCUSSED ON THESE
PRIORITY POPULATIONS AND
EXECUTING THE EVACUATIONS THAT
THE PRESIDENT HAS ORDERED.
>> WHERE IS THE PRESIDENT?
WHY ISN'T HE COMMUNICATING
WHOLESOMELY TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE?
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN DEEPLY
ENGAGED IN ALL OF THE POLICY
CONVERSATIONS AND IN THIS
SITUATION AS IT EVOLVES IN
REALTIME.
WE HAVE MET WITH THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS ENTIRE NATIONAL SECURITY
TEAM DAILY, OFTEN MULTIPLE TIMES
A DAY.
THAT WILL CONTINUE AGAIN TODAY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS SPOKEN TO THIS
ISSUE A NUMBER OF TIMES IN
RECENT WEEKS.
>> HE HAS NOT -- LOOK, JOHN,
TOTALLY DIFFERENT STORY THAN A
FEW WEEKS AGO, RIGHT?
WHY ISN'T HE OUT THERE NOW?
KABUL FELL YESTERDAY.
WHERE IS THE PRESIDENT?
>> AGAIN, BRIANNA, THE PRESIDENT
HAS SPOKE ON THE THIS
EXTENSIVELY AND I EXPECT HE WILL
SPEAK TO IT AGAIN SOON.
>> SOON IN THE COMING DAYS
SHOULD WE HEAR SOMETHING FROM
HIM TODAY?
DO YOU EXPECT IT?
IT SEEMS LIKE THE MOMENT DEMANDS
THAT?
>> I WON'T GET
ALL I CAN SAY IS THAT AS SOON AS
WE HAVE AN UPDATE WE'LL BRING IT
TO YOU.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE THOSE ARE JUST
PEOPLE AT THE AIRPORT.
DO YOU HAVE A HANDLE ON THE
NUMBERS?
ARE THERE THAT MANY PEOPLE AT
THE AIRPORT RIGHT NOW?
>> THAT'S NOT JUST PEOPLE AT THE
AIRPORT.
THESE ARE PEOPLE, AGAIN, IN
PARTICULAR CATEGORIES, PEOPLE
WHO WORKED ALONGSIDE THE UNITED
STATES' MISSION THE LAST TWO
DECADES, MANY OF WHOM ARE
APPLYING FOR A SPECIAL PROGRAM
VISA CREATE BID CONGRESS WHO
FACE ADDITIONAL RISKS BECAUSE
THEY SUPPORTED OUR MISSION.
WE'VE STARTED TO BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF EVACUATING LOCAL
STAFF OF OUR MISSION IN
AFGHANISTAN, OUR EMBASSY AND OUR
AFGHANS WHO ARE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE BECAUSE OF THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THAT WILL BE THE FOCUS AS WELL
AS, AS YOU SAY, AMERICAN
CITIZENS WHO HAPPEN TO BE
PRESENT IN AFGHANISTAN, OF WHICH
THERE SAY SIGNIFICANT NUMBER.
WE'LL BE MAKING EVACUATION
FLIGHTS AVAILABLE TO THEM AS
WELL.
>> THESE AREN'T JUST PEOPLE AT
THE AIRPORT YOU'RE GOING TO
EVACUATE BUT ALSO SAY YOU CAN'T
PROVIDE SAFE PASSAGE FOR PEOPLE
TO THE AIRPORT.
SO, HOW IS IT NOT JUST PEOPLE AT
THE AIRPORT?
>> WE ARE GOING TO BE PROVIDING
SECURITY AT THE AIRPORT.
AND THE PEOPLE GETTING ON THESE
FLIGHTS ARE GOING TO BE PEOPLE
WHO ARE SELECTED BASED ON
PRIORITY CATEGORIES WE
IDENTIFIED.
>> ARE THE 30,000 PEOPLE WHO ARE
HOLED UP AT THE AIRPORT AND, I
GUESS QUALIFY IS WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING.
BUT WHEN I ASKED YOU IF IT'S
JUST PEOPLE AT THE AIRPORT, ARE
YOU TRYING TO SAY THAT
UNDERNEATH THAT CATEGORY ARE A
NUMBER OF AFGHANS AND AMERICANS
WHO MAY NOT BE AT THE AIRPORT?
AND IF SO, WHEN DO YOU GET THEM?
>> WE ARE ASKING PEOPLE WHEN
THEIR FLIGHT IS CALLED -- IT'S
NOT JUST A FREE FOR ALL.
IT CAN'T, FOR SECURITY REASONS,
WORK THAT WAY.
WHEN PEOPLE'S FLIGHTS ARE TIMED
WE'RE ASKING THEM TO SHOW UP AT
THE AIRPORT TO GET ON THOSE
FLIGHTS.
WE HAVE MESSAGED QUITE CLEARLY
BOTH TO APPLICANTS AND PEOPLE
WHO MIGHT BE ELIGIBLE FOR THESE
FLIGHTS AS WELL AS PUBLICLY THAT
CASE.
THIS WILL BE ESTABLISHING A
CLEAR SECURITY AT THE AIRPORT
AND THAT IS THE MAIN FOCUS OF
TH